in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kevin
and Ali are with us as we continue our
debt-free Peluso or hey guys how are you
we're doing great where do you all live
we're from Grand Rapids Michigan welcome
to Nashville
thank you have you how much of YouTube
paid off just over a hundred and two
thousand way to go how long did that
take around 40 months just a little over
40 months okay and your range of income
during that time 70 210 cool what do you
guys do for a living I'm a social worker
and I'm a web developer cool very cool
well good to have you guys what kind of
debt was the hundred and two
it was mostly student loans and some car
debt how much was on the cars was like
roughly around twelve thousand okay yeah
Sallie Mae had really taken up residence
with y'all she really had so how long
have you two been married three and a
half years that's oh so you started this
one you got married
okay so whose idea was that the
counselors or one of you two well it was
her mom's idea and I was reluctant to be
honest to take Financial Peace
University but once we got into the
program I just latched onto it and went
a little crazy so you started off your
marriage with your mother-in-law being
right that's great yeah so what was the
biggest thing about the class that made
you actually go do the stuff yeah so I
think when it was a lesson about a
gazelle running from a lion that was
that was really powerful for me and so I
just took root and me I was like man we
got it we got to take care of this and
get it done so that's right yeah so we
we did it we started up a small business
to help us pay off the loans
oh cool what kind of small business did
you start we do wedding videography so
good okay yep on the side good yeah and
that could be pretty decent money yeah
again yeah good for you guys
well done did you sell anything big I'm
not necessarily big but we just had you
know he like he said it's a web
developer so we had what we called the
computer junkyard you know the old
salvage yard okay all right and and so
people make fun of you while you're
doing this I don't know what make fun of
but we definitely got Alicante she's on
the budget yeah little snide comments or
their sarcasm now definitely happen but
but there they didn't pay off 100 2040
months and you did that's right way to
go how does it feel now to not have any
day crazy really freeing honestly like
we don't know what to do so whose debt
was it the student loans both go back to
grad school kind of in the middle of it
so I did rack up a little bit more in
there okay we we both went to private
school and so that racks it up pretty
quick so yeah that's that's what
happened okay so take me through this
conversation with your mother ally how
did she broke that subject well I think
she had just my grandma and my mom have
listened to your show for a while and we
were going to church and there was an
advertisement and so she was like hey
you guys like it'd be really great to
you know kind of start off on this foot
we had been together for a while and
like you said we were both in private
school so kind of financials or a little
all over the place and so she just was
she actually offered to pay for you know
the class for us to kind of start that
often during the engagement exactly
alright so that doesn't sound too over
the top is just like this would be good
for you and I'll pay for it yeah pretty
nice yeah but we still do have to admit
that you started your marriage off with
your mother-in-law being right I mean
that's just that's classic right there
I'm love it I love it I love it alone
that's fun well very cool very cool
congratulations you two very very proud
of you thank you you got to feel great
about yourself we do I mean you can you
can attack and do anything that's right
very cool that's exciting
so we're gonna give you a copy of course
of Chris Hogan's number one bestseller
excellent tyre inspired because that's
the next thing to build that wealth and
put you in a position to live and give
like no one else and that's the net
result I mean if you can knock off a
hundred and two thousand you can save a
million dollars yeah you can do it it's
what's gonna happen to you especially at
your age you guys really got a great
start and hats off to mother-in-law okay
all right Kevin and Ally Grand Rapids
Michigan a hundred and two thousand paid
off in 40 months making 70 to 110 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar in
common